*Mark's outro for horror games (Haunted by Shirk) plays as he dances*
Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to a fan-made game
called Markiplier Adventures 2.
Now, this is a sequel to Markiplier Adventures 1,
which was made by JeffKyler14
about two or three years ago now.
He's done a lot of cool things, he's even made an animation for me,
and this game has been in the works for so long.
He's told me about all the struggles that he've had
to try to finish it just with personal stuff in his life.
But it finally came out, and it came out a
couple of months agos, and I wanted
In-Game Mark: (yawn)
Mark: to play it- oh...
In-Game Mark: Boy do I feel better!
Mark: Is that supposed to be me?
Is that me?
"Boy, do I feel better!"
Hello!
In-Game Mark: I guess that game took a lot out of me
Mark:*laughter* I- who's
(voice cracking) doing an impression of me?!
Who- who is that?
That's not me!
"I guess that game took a lot out of me!"
Oh... "Later that morning."
In-Game Mark: I'm coming!
Mark: Oh, THAT's a weird thing to shout.
Okay.
Hello?
In-Game Mark: Weird...It doesn't have any--
AHHH!!!!!
Mark: (giggles)
Ahhhhhh, that's hilarious.
In-Game Mark: Wha--
"Wh-"
*small giggles*
In-Game Mark: Where am I? And why do this plot seem Cliché?
Mark: I don't know! I didn't make it!
Oh, boy...
In-Game Mark: The hell?
Mark: "The hell?" (giggles)
Tiny Box Tim:AHHHHH
OOHHHHHHH!
Tiny Box Tim: HELP ME!!
In-Game Mark: Oh no! Tiny Box Tim!!
Mark: (laughter)
In-Game Mark: Tim, are you okay?
Tiny Box Tim: I'm okay Mark. Thanks to you!
Mark: Awwwwww!
In-Game Mark: I'll never let anyone or anything hurt you my little biscut!
Mark: Awwwww!
Tiny Box Tim: Thank you, Mark!
Mark: Awww!
In-Game Mark: I guess we have to follow this path
Mark: Yeah, the weird path that was drawn.
Okay!
We're gonna go on an adventure!
Oh yeah, so this game came out a while-
er, uh, the first part of this game came out a while ago,
A-And it's just really cool- Oh my god...
We're in a comic book!
"Click to throw Warfstaches."
*POOF*
(laughing) Pohoohohoof!
"The scribbles won't hurt you."
Then why did I blow it up?!
I just blew it the fuck up!
Huh! Poof!
They won't hurt me?
Oh, they won't hurt me.
Well, why would I kill them all?
Ha-Poof! (chuckling)
Poof!
Deadly poof balls!
Oh, gee- oh my god!
That's, like, the original dubstep music that I
l- that I used so long ago! I remember that stuff!
I- The first time I ever made an outro, I used this music
just because it was part of the...
the Fall of Slenderman.
I didn't make an outro, until the Fall of S- Oh...
Sorry! Ah, shit, I gotta go all the way back.
Well, I am an idiot,
and I do fail a lot at everything that I try to do.
So it's to be expected that I suck ass and die.
Alright...
Heh, heH, HEh, Heh, HEh.
But anyways, yeah, so...
That was way back in the Fall of Slenderman that this
particular brand of music is being played.
Hep, hep hep!
Piff!
Piff, piff, AH!
FUCKING, GOD DAMNIT! I'm SUCH A BAG of DICK!
Oh yeah!
Poy-yah!
I don't know why- why am I still killing
all the scribbles?
They literally won't hurt me, they're just peaceful
things in this world!
And I'm blowing up everything.
Because I'm a dick.
Okay.
We got this!
Haauuuhhh!
HiYAH! There we go!
Ho, boy! OH, BOY!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, man. This is a lot harder than I thought it'd be!
(in a sing-song manner) HEAADUDaDuDaDuDaDuDaDu!
YAY! I MADE IT!
WHERE AM I NOW?
In-Game Mark: I think this is it...the way out
Mark: Is it now,
*deep voice* fake me...
Yeah?
In-Game Mark: Woooah
Mark: I know right? Whoa...
Tiny Box Time: I can't believe how amazing this place looks!
Mark: Heh- It loo- What is this with the sun?! And
what's this green stuff on the ground?
Oh my god! IS THAT DIRT?!
In-Game Mark: I know, right?
Mark: Whoop, shit!
Ah, fuck!
Tiny Box Tim: Don't worry Mark, I got your back! Let's go!
Mark: Okay! I don't know what challenge we're facing, but
I know that you got my back, and that's what's important, Tim!
Here we go! I guess?
Wherever the hell we are.
I don't know how I got here, or why I'm here, but I'm good.
Okay!
h- HUEH! heAUH! HEUf!
WHAT?!
I don't know what big toe of what penis monster
I saw over there, but what the hell was that?!
I just saw a leg, and it wasn't a... it wasn't-
FUCKING! God dammit! I'm such dickatry!
Alright, guys. Enough sucking ass. It's time to get to work here.
Eh! Eh!
Fffffuck! I'm bad! How can I be this bad
at platformers? No wonder I-
(giggling) No wonder I'm a terrible gamer.
No wonder I'm a disgrace to gamers all over the world!
Wha- IT WAS A PENIS MONSTER!
It was! It's MMMMMMMMMMM.
(laughter)
MMMMMMMMMMM
MMmm
MMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
Mm! Those are some big Mmmmms!
Oh my god!
The disgusting flesh monsters that are Mmmmm
from the Spore series.
(FNAF music starts)
Oh, boy... This looks bad!
Well, that's the Five Nights at Freddy's music right there.
Oh, this is so cool! Going through, like, all these different games.
Oh, it's so coo- What's in the distance over there?
Is this supposed to be Slenderman or something else?
Because It's been a while since I've played a Slenderman game.
It's been a while since there's been a Slenderman game made.
God, that craze has died down.
And it's weird to think that the uh- the Five Nights at Freddy's craze
is lasting longer than the Slenderman craze did.
Because that was... that was ridiculous when that first happened.
I mean, it was first the Amnesia craze, and then Slenderman came about,
and then a slew of other indie horror games.
And then there was a bit of a drip-
A drip- a drop.
In-Game Mark: You've got to be kidding me...
Mark: What? WHAT DO YOU SEE?!
Tiny Box Tim: (scared voice) Do we really have to go in there?
(Mark sighs)
In-Game Mark: I'm afraid so Tim...
Mark: Oh, I know...
And I think in the original Markiplier Adventures, there definitely was Slenderman.
Oh, hello... Oh, hello...
I do appreciate all the art too, that's something that JeffKyler definitely worked on.
Er- his name is actually John I think.
Uh, but, just something that he's worked on so hard and I appreciate the all the labor of love-
In-Game Mark and TTT:
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
(Mark inhales)
-that's been put into this game!
And I- just- it- it's dripping, with, like...
history, and it's dripping with these cool references, and it's dripping with
all sorts of stuff--
???: Are you alright, Mark? You look pretty down....
Mark: (giggling)
Heh! Is that Warfstache?!
(Warfstache voice) "Are you alright Mark? You look pretty down..."
*giggles*
In-Game Mar: W-Wilford Warfstache?!
Mark: Could it be?!
Warfstahce: Good evening, Mark
(Mark laughs)
I just heard you falling down here, so I'm keeping you safe from Freddy and the others roaming the area
Mark: Aw, man... I- I- I should volunteer to do the voice acting
for this, because I wanna make sure that it's good.
But I'm not saying it's bad, WHOA, HANG ON, BACK UP, I'M NOT SAYING IT'S BAD!
I'M NOT- I'M NOT SAYING IT'S BAD
BUT I'M RIGHT HERE, AND I COULD DO IT, so I could do it!
I- I wanna- I wanna contact- uh, him so, uh, I can actually do the voice acting for this, because it's really cool.
But I'm gonna allow him-
or whoever's doing the voice acting to carry on, because, this is their baby, their labor of love, and it's really cool.
In-Game Mark: Woah, Woah, Woah, Woah. Wait a minute. Wait a minute!
In-Game Mark: I thought you were dead...
Mark: Yeah, he's been dead a lot.
Warfstahce: I got revived by some dude
Mark: (Warfstache voice) "I got revived by some dude."
In-Game Mark: Oh....
Mark: Heh.
(Freddy Laughs)
Oh, by some dude. Was it... purple guy?!
Warstache: You're on your own now
(Mark laughs)
Good Luck!
Mark: Oh, thanks, Warfstache! Thanks for disappearing in a poof cloud of pink!
In-Game Mark: What the frick!?
Mark: Oh, I say (laughs) fuck
thank you.
Tiny Box Tim: MARK!
In-Game Mark: Tim!?
Mark: Whoa, Tim got big!
In-Game Mark: Are you okay?
Mark: What the hell- oh!
(TTT: I'm fine Mark!)
Oh, okay!
(Freddy laughs)
Wha-ha! Whoa!
In-Game Mark: Let's get out of here
Mark: Oh, boy!
Oh, boy!!
Oh, boy!!!
I don't think I'm gonna survive this one!
So, were you just playing with all the Big Box Barries?
Were they finally nice to you for once in their lives-?
Oh...
Hello! POOF!
That's right! Ge- POOF! POOF!
Yeah, that's right, you don't want to mess with me!
I don't want to mess with me!
No on wants to- what happens- whoa. (POOF! POOF!) I can see it...
(Freddy screams)
FUCKING FUCK, OKAY THEN!
HOLY SHIT! Are all of them just Freddy?
(Freddy Sceam)
Hello, Freddy! Okay, goodbye, Freddy!
Alright, I see how this is. Ha-POOF! Ha-POOF!
Ha-POOF, POOF. POOF!
POOOOHOHOOOF! (laughter)
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
*giggles*
That's gonna get annoying real quick!
Well, not to me. I never get tired of Poof.
FUCKIN'... There was no one there!
That was a lie! I should just keep up the spam.
I'm gonna kill all you bastards!
*continuous Poofs*
Hah!
Poof, poof, poof!
Poof, poof, foof?
'Kay. Alright, then.
Man, this is really cool. I like this a lot!
I mean, it's actually kind of amazing what he's managed to do-
What he's managed to do with just a platformer.
Because, platformers, are like, the ubiquitous gaming-
Wh- There was nothing there!
God dammit, I am just gonna keep spamming if you're gonna do that!
Platformers are some of the most simple games to make,
but, it's just, the character AROUND the platformer, and it's like
what you do with the art and the environment,
and what it means in the story. Like, that's what really makes
like, a platformer actually come together, and I really do appreciate all that's been done here.
And it's just- it's just charming and delightful!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
IT'S CHARMING AND DELIGHTFUL! AHHHHHHHHHHHuuuAAHHHH
Ohhhh! There was one hidden there! Okay, so there are ones in the darkness.
They will not stop me!
Oh! No-! Ooh! Anyone there?
Huh? It's just- if I was actually in f- uh, i-in a Five Nights at Freddy's restaurant and I had some sort of weapon
with me, you better believe your ASS that I'd be spamming it everywhere I go!
'specially one that would just shoot Warfstaches non-stop.
HAAAHHHHHHH- Whoa.
H-Hey, whoa!
Oh, yay!
???: I knew I'd fine you here
Mark: Who the hell- Nurse?
Nurse?
In-Game Mark: Nurse?!
(laughter) Nurhurse?!
In-Game Mark: What are you doing here?!
Mark: What ARE you doing here?!
Nurse: I should ask you the same thing
Mark: Ah, man, get a- get a better fitting shirt!
What are you doing here? There are kids watching! What's going on here, Nurse?
Tiny Box Tim: Mark, I think I got a bad feeling about this...
Uh-oh. Is it not Nurse?
Nurse: Oh! Who's your little friend?
(Tiny Box Tim whines)
Mark: Awww, hah, aww!
Don't be afraid of Nurse, she's probably not a monstrosity.
In-Game Mark: That's Tiny Box Tim! He's my little biscuit!
Mark: "He's my little biscuit!"
Nurse: Aww--
--He's so adorable!
Mark: Haha, awww!
(TTT: Oohh)
(deep voice) Something bad is goin' happen
In-Game Mark: WHHHHHAT?!
Mark: Whaaaat?
(giggly pouting)
In-Game Mark: I didn't say anything
Mark: I-I said something!
Tiny Box Tim and Nurse:
Riiiiiight
Mark: Riiiiight (giggling)
I just love that her shirt, is just two buttons, barely contained by her boobs.
In-Game Mark: Nurse, first off you were in the game I played and now you're in this comic book.
Mark: Ahhhh
In-Game Mark: What happened?!
Mark: Yeah, what happened?
Nurse: Well Mark, It's a long story, but I guess I might as well tell it.
Mark: Alright, sure, I won't tell you to shut up this time.
Nurse: You see the last time we met--
Mark: Yeah.
--You got stabbed in your butt--
Mark: Yeah
--But that insane Jeff bardged in and nearly killed us. When you told me to escape, I went through a vent that lead to the outside of the Hospital--
Mark: Oooh, okay!
--As soon as I made it out, a vortex appeared out of nowhere and the next thing I know of, I was home--
Mark: Yay!
--Anyways, this morning, I was getting ready to go to work, but as soon as I opened my front door, I saw this comic book on my doorstep, and decided to look into it--
Mark: Ooohhh.
--But then I got sucked in. Seemed like forever ago now, But I also fought off a ton of hordes of Demons and here I am
Mark: Oooh, okay--
In-Game Mark: SHUT UP NURSE!!!!!
Mark: NO, KEEP TALKING, I'M VERY INTERESTING IN THIS STORY!
Nurse: What did you just say to me?!
Sorry, it's an interior reflex! I've got a tumor in my amygdala, it just makes me say that.
In-Game Mark: Uhhhh...
Keep calm nurse you know what's best!
(Mark chuckles)
Mark: Maybe
Nurse: You're alright, Mark.....
Mark: Heh. "YOU'RE ALRIGHT THERE."
Oh, okay.
Aw, man, I was a bit of a- now I feel bad! Now that you're
personified, and not an actual, you know, not just a
figment of my imagination!
Y'know, the whole concept of the Nurse, was that I was a doctor operating alone, and then
and then, the nurse was an alternate personality of mine,
that was just like,
There wasn't- there was- here's the big secret!
For all of you who have watched my Surgeon Simulators, in my mind, in those instances,
the Nurse didn't exist!
The Nurse was just me as the doctor going,
(high-pitched voice) But doctor, I think you're doing- (normal voice) SHUT UP, VOICE INSIDE MY HEAD!
That's- that's who (laughter) the Nurse was.
(continued laughter)
But I like this better, this makes me seem... less... crazy...
Ooh!
"Even though this is true, that never really happens in this story."
"LIIIKE, no joke."
I WOULD... NEVER!
(gasp)
OHHHHHHH!!!
OHHHHH!
OHOHOHOHO!
OOHOHO, NOOO!!
THAT'S SO CUTE!
OH NO!
I KNOW WHAT THE NEXT PLUSHY'S GONNA BE!
OH, IT'S SO CUUTE!
(laughter)
That's what the sound of love is:
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!
(laughter)
Oh, oh no. I- I- I'd go for it.
Awww, haha, aww.
Uh-huh.
(in-game is deep and creepy for the last line)
I don't think I- that's- that's really creepy.
(laughter)
Awwww, man.
Aw, that's cool
Heh. D-Dammit. My best effort. It's all to waste. I bought this fedora for nothing!
"I do me!"
I do me so hard (chuckling)
Oh, there's so many references! I love it!
Oh it's so cool- What is that? Is that a giant ass on the ground?
Oh. Oh, no, it's a mannequin. I thought it was a giant buttocks.
Let's see if I can make that face.
That was pretty good.
No, I do not!
It's very true.
'Cause they're fucking creepy!
"I just hate them." They don't belong!
They're not real!
Uh oh. Well, that's not good.
Ahh!
AHHH!!!
(giggling) "Wh-Whuat?!"
Oh, that's so cool!
Yeah, I- you can tell he's, uh, been working on it for a long time, because
some of these references are from 2014.
And, I mean, it's cool that it spans it all, I'm not saying that it's any bad sort of thing
that it takes place a long time ago, but it's so coo- I love it all!
HHEEEYYYYY! I don't like THAT!
OOOOOH, no thank you!
(laughter)
(deep voice) "I'll send you to hell..."
Oh geez!
POOOOO-AAAHAHAAA!!!
Whoa, my god, why do they have to shoot blood explosions?
That seems unnecessary!
I mean- I'm- I'm, uh, appreciative of it.
Hwa-hya!
No, get out of my way!
Whoa, FUUUUUCK ME! Okay.
Ha, ha! You can't beat my spam!
You can't beat my epic spam!
OHHHHH
(drawing out the vowel sound) GOD!
(screaming)
AHHHHHH, CAN'T KEEP UP, YES!
I did it all! I didn't even stop runnning the whole way!
Nurse!
Oh, no!
It's not Nurse, is it?
Oh. What the f-?
(giggling) The fuck is that? Is that Warfstache?
In a Nurse costume? (laughing, fake scream)
(exaggerated fake scream)
Okay, bye!
Thanks!
I don't know, man.
(giggling)
Good thing I have an infinite amount of explosive... (laughter)
mustaches shooting out of my nipples!
Ah, man, that would've been better if I had been able to say that correctly.
Heh. Too pro, waaay too pro.
My dark ego?
Who's that? You talkin' about...
(deep voice) Darkiplier?
Oh, hi guys!
Oh! That's right! Bob in his Dexter outfit!
Oh, I love it!
Heh. "Yes." That's Wade's voice.
"Y-Yes."
(laughter)
Mm. My Nurse, I own her.
Oh, Jesus!
Oh man, you guys, that's- that's inappropriate!
Oh, boy.
It was a simple sexual harassment, that's what it was!
Uh-huh, yeah. WHOA!
DE-MONS!
He-heh, what kind of demons-
Uhhh, okay. Die!
(chuckling) I'm gonna purify them
I'm gonna purify 'em
Nah, sounds more like Wade.
(chuckles) I love it!
I love this! 'Cause I remember all of this! That's from Markiplier's Magic Touch!
Oh, hello, MMMMM.
Oh, hi. Hello.
"I got this..."
I got it!
Me, I got it.
Am I gonna be riding MMMM?
YEEEAAAAH!!!
HELL YEAH!
OH, YOU THINK, YOU CAN MESS WITH THE LIKES OF POOF?!
Oh my god!
Yeah, I don't think they stand a chance. I'm pretty sure I've won already.
We're just riding into the sunset here.
It's not really a threat anymore, it's just us.
NOOOOOPE!
Welp, that's one down.
Heh. This sure is easy!
Yeah! I, uh, I'm way to pro for this!
My mustache flinging skills is incredible! I love poof!
I love poof so much!
It's the most innocuous thing that's ever come out of a video!
And yet, it's so pervasive.
Like, forever. It'll- Poof'll never die.
Oh, NOW you're starting to get a little bit of a challenge, huh?
I mean, still not much of a challenge, but SOME sort of a challenge.
Okay, now my fingers are starting to get tired; I shouldn't have wasted my poof skills earlier on.
Uuuhhh!
Oooh! MAXIMUM POOFAGE!
I think we might've done it. Did we do it? Did we done it?
Are we done? YEAH!
(kissing his arms) Did it! Done it!
Dones it, doneroni!
Din dono!
Completo!
"Oh my god!"
Ohohohoho!
"Well, well, well..."
"YOU!!!"
Yeah!
Uh? Ohohohoho!
YEAH! C'MON! FIST-A-CUFF ME, BRO!
Don't take that as "fist me, bro!"
I DON'T!
DOES TINY BOX TINA BELIEVE IN ME, BECAUSE MAYBE THIS IS GONNA GO OKAY!
Oh!
LET'S DO THIS! COME ON!
I'm ready! I don't know what I'm doing, but I hope I can still shoot mustaches. WHOA!
Oh! Well fuck... AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
Welp, that was easy.
(laughter)
(in Darkiplier's voice) AH, MY MASTER PLAN! (normal voice) Why does everything poof?
WOOOOOHOOOOO!
Oh....
M-Maybe. Maybe a little bit.
Oooh, nooo.
Oh, no.
(chuckling)
Oh, boy!
Oh, no!
Wait, do I go- do I go here? No. No, apparently I don't! That's-
Oh, god. Apparently I don't do that, because that would be stupid!
Whoa, what is this?
What am I doing? AM I ABOUT TO ROCK MY SOCKS OFF? Whoa!
I- I don't think I can make that jump!
HUP! NOPE! Oooooh, I know what I need to do!
I got it, I got it. I gotta bang this giant rock testicle here.
POOOOOOF!!!!
Oh. Well. Ow.
Oh.
Uh oh!
Uh oh! Uh oh!
(laughter)
I am Luciplier?!
With a... mustache chest hair, is that what I'm seeing?
Yeah, I'll try anyway. I'll give it my best- OH, BOY!
Oh no, is that his ankle or his ballsack?
Oh no, it's his arm, it's okay.
Wow, look at those ABS.
ABS for DAYS, Abs for YEARS, Abs for MILLENNIA!
Oh, gosh!
I don't know where I'm going, but I hope- hope I, uh- hope I know what I'm doing and, and-
GOOD THING EVERYBODY'S  HELPING ME IN THE DISTANCE, LOCKED UP IN THOSE CAGES. HA!
Alright, here we go. Well,  I- I guess I'm bravely running away!
Oh, shit!
Oh, shit, dude!
OH, SHIT!
AHHHHH!
YEAH!
Oh, shit! Oh fuck! Oh, god, yes! Oh, hell, yes!
AFWOOSH!
AHHHHHHHAH!
YEAH! KILL 'EM! KILL 'EM DEAD! STAB HIM IN HIS DICK!
YEAH! RIGHT UP THE BUTT! STAB HIS BUTT!
Oh, shit!
"You've been purified!"
AHHAHAHUAAAHHH!
Oh...
Oh- Oh, no! I didn't know you guys were all at risk here!
Uh...
Aw. AWWW, NO! Tina, don't cry!
Awwwww...
That's so sweet
I'M NOT DEAD, YAY!
EVERYONE, CHEER!
Awwww...
He-heh!
Awww!
Awwwwhahaawww! Awww
Oh, whoops! I interrupted Tiny Box Tim's celebrating there.
Oh! Apparently I'm ascending! GOODBYE, EVERYBODY! GOODBYE! WOOOOHOOOOO!!!
I WAS NEVER ALIVE TO BEGIN WITH- Oh, wait. No, here we go.
Oh. Oh shit. Oh, fuck, dude. Oooh.
Aww... That's really...
That was good...
I liked that.
I liked that a lot.
It was good.
Aw man, I'm so glad that he finished it
That was so good. Aw, I liked that.
"Congratulations Mark! You over your second adventure... through a comic book?
Seriously? Well, things seem to get weirder everyday.
Anyways, you overcame many obstacles, and yourself of three forms.
But does this mean it's over?
You may be say- safe as of now... but the final chapter of your adventure await you.
Therefore...
To be continued."
Oh, yes!
Please! Oh, my god!
Ehhhh!
Geez *sniff* Aw man, I'm be- I'm being such a doof.
But that is so good, I love that a lot, that is so cool!
Like, it just- it means a lot that these things are made!
Yeah, John J. Howell, JeffKlyer14.
He's an amazing artist, and just, like...
dedicated to this! Because, I can tell that, y'know, this was started a long time ago, but I'm so glad he finally finished it, because...
it means a lot that this was here, and it means a lot that y'know, these things, like, exist
And, y'know, I can see, like, the voice of the community come through things like this.
And, I can see- I can see how you guys picture what I do through things like this.
And, y'know, that really... y'know, that makes me really happy, to know it's...
it's, um... it's- it- it- it comes through like this, an- and- and
"MST3Kman," er musket man, I think it is.
just... it's fuckin' awesome. I remember, all, all the... and, y'know, they did it, and... y'know, I
I- I... and I remember all the... because, over five years, you see a lot of things and you meet a lot of people, and, y'know...
*sniff* I do remember! I remember, I, y'know, remember... er, I remember.
Uh, yeah I want to see a message from the creator of the game, hell yeah I do.
"Thank you for playing my game, I one day hope to follow my dreams as a cartoonist, game designer, and let's player.
Mark, you inspired me to be a better person and I wouldn't be anywhere right now if it weren't for you and your fans.
Even if the person reading this isn't Mark, I really appreciate your support.
If you're willing to check out my content, fell free to subcribe to my YouTube channel, JeffKyler14, and my game channel JeffKyler14Games. (GO SUBSCRIBE RIGHT NOW. GO. NOW.)
With lots of love, I'll see you in the next video. Buh-Bye! ~John J. Howell."
And that's really cool!
'Cause of, like... it, it's what it represents, in a lot of what happened
in MY life, and- and over time, how my videos have affected people.
And that's what's really cool about it! That's what I love about it! And that's what I love about these- these games,
and what they- they show me, like they showcase the things that I've done, and- and the way that it's touched people, like, that's...
It's super important to me, so... *sniff* I just wanted to say thank you to, uh, JeffKyler14, please go subscribe to his YouTube channels,
please follow him on Twitter, send him all the love in the world for this stuff, because these creative things that're... made for me! Like...
hours and hours and hours of work, dedicated for me, like... I- I feel bad, because I don't see them...
Like, I don't see all of them, and I want to, and I want to know 'em all, and, like, it's really important that it's all there, so...
Just, Thank you everybody so much for being here, and thank you everybody so much for showing me, and reminding me, of...
of, like, the things that I've done, and the person that I've become, because, I- I- I- I never want to lose sight of that.
And it's something that I've, like, reinvigorated myself in, in these past few months, and I'm very happy to be back where I was
And I'm just really happy to be doing this again, so...
I'll wrap this up before I get too weepy *clears throat*
So thank you everybody so much for watching, thank you everybody who has ever made me art, or made me a game. I wanna know about it.
There's a DeviantART group that's been around since- since I've been on YouTube, uh, I'll put a link to all of this in the description.
If you have art, I wanna see it, if you have a game that you've made, I wanna see it.
I may not a make a video about everything, y'know, but... I just want to I want to see it, y'know?
So, thank you everybody for watching for watching, thank you everybody who's made something over the years,
and thank you for... like, sticking with me for so long. Like, there's such a history on this channel, and I'm so proud of everything that's been done.
'Cause it means so much to me! So...
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you...
In the next video.
BUH-BYE!
*outro music plays*